when people become sick they normally go
to the doctor practice self-medication
or in the worst cases summon a witch
doctor you know however when our
protagonist's sister Falls sick with a
deadly and incurable disease she decides
to go to extreme lengths something which
has never been done before she actually
goes to Egypt resurrects one of the Dead
mummies and orders it to treat her dying
sister the plan is a risky one but it is
the only hope she has following this the
movie cuts to a few days in the past in
Paris a middle-aged man named chupard is
heading back home after a long day at
work he's drunk disheveled and in
desperate need of relieving himself with
nowhere to go shupard decides to answer
Nature's call in the most unconventional
of places right in front of a massive
statue however as he is about to finish
a strange light emits from nearby
causing him to run away in fear it was
probably the cops Pro tip don't pee on
the street in Europe unless you want to
go to jail the scene then cuts to the
home of an eminent professor of physics
Mary Joseph AKA Jose he has Decades of
experience in the field and many believe
that he can even perform witchcraft Jose
also has extensive knowledge of ancient
Egypt and at the moment he is busy with
telepathic experiments he holds the
belief that life is possible after death
following this we are taken to the
National Museum of Natural History where
a huge 136 million year old egg of a
pterosaur is kept lo and behold Jose
makes use of his telepathic powers to
hatch the old egg and a massive
pterosaur emerges from it it turns out
the professor can control the bird's
physical movements so he makes it fly
through the glass ceiling however when
he loses Focus for a split second it
lands on top of a passing car this
results in a deadly crash killing all
the passengers inside coincidentally
shupard Witnesses the incident and
reports it to the police in the report
he details how a dinosaur caused the car
to fall into the river when the General
Public to know about this they are left
in utter shock many of them even stopped
going to work fearing that the dinosaur
May attack them too therefore the
president of frost orders the National
Police to make the case their top
priority we are then introduced to Andre
zaboro oh God it's Borowski a young man
who spends his days working as Dr
Menard's assistant at a Botanical Garden
he has a deep passion for reading and is
an Ardent admirer of The Adventurous
author Adele Blanc sec in his free time
he pens letters to her hoping that he
can win her heart but despite his
persistence Adele shows no interest in
his advances leaving Andre heartbroken
and frustrated she is currently on an
adventure in Egypt to retrieve the mummy
of patmosis a popular scholar and an
advisor to the Egyptian Pharaoh Ramses
II despite the whole operation being
illegal Adele hires two local Egyptians
and manages to sneak into patmosis's
Tome with her sharp mind she then
unlocks the entrance which was being
blocked by a a wall after gaining entry
into the tomb the two men reveal their
true colors it turns out they are
thieves who are after The Jewels buried
in the Tomb they threaten Adele and try
to send her away only to realize that
they can't exit the place without her
help therefore the thieves agree to let
her get the mummy while they keep the
gold after a while they eventually
locate the coffin which is filled with
Millions worth of treasure as they start
pocketing It Adele tries to locate an
alternate exit to carry the heavy coffin
out of the Tomb unfortunately something
sets the tomb's anti-theft mechanism
into motion and it kills the Thieves for
trying to steal the jewels Adele is
stunned by the sudden turn of events but
before she can even process what
happened a professor named devou storms
into the tomb with police it's evident
that the two know each other very well
and the voodoo demands to know why she
is after the mummy left with no choice
Adele finally reveals that she wants to
seek patmosis's help to heal her dying
sister although the mummy is dead she
believes that it can be resurrected as
mentioned in Professor Jose's book
unsurprisingly this only makes divu
burst into laughter and he arrogantly
tells her that it's an impossible
concept he then orders the police to
arrest her turns out they are planning
to execute her without trial Adele is
given One Last Wish and she uses it to
ask for a cigarette however when she is
given one she shoves devou into the
mummy making machine and sets the tomb
on fire she then quickly jumps into
patmosis's coffin and pushes it into a
large well that is connected to a river
from the bottom meanwhile Professor
Divas henchmen rescue him just in time
at the Natural History Museum Professor
Maynard notices the broken pterodactylag
other staff members assume that a
visitor vandalized the Aging glass
ceiling however the theory has proven to
be false when Maynard notices that the
shells of the egg are still connected to
the amniotic membrane this means that an
internal Force cracked the egg which
further means that the pterodactyl
emerged from it and flew away through
the glass soon inspector Capone arrives
to investigate the matter but Maynard
hides his finding things and instead
advises him to meet Professor Jose
meanwhile at Jose's residence he is busy
feeding the giant pterodactyl when
there's a sudden knock on the door to
his surprise it's the cunning inspector
Capone in his state of panic Jose
hastily hides the Colossal bird behind
thick curtains hoping to avoid any
unwanted attention however Capone
invites himself in for lunch leaving
Jose with no other option but to
entertain his Uninvited Guest as he
serves boiled eggs to the inspector the
pterodactyl suddenly becomes aggressive
and attacks Capone before flying away
this scares the life out of the
inspector and he orders his men to take
the professor into custody who does this
guy think he is Hagrid in the next scene
Adele brings the mummy back home from
Egypt she lives with her ailing sister
who is completely bedridden it's then
revealed that the latter ended up in
this state after a long hairpin got
stuck in her head meanwhile Adele
notices the million letters Andre has
sent to her but as always she pays them
dust and goes on a better day later that
day Adele comes across Andre dropping
yet another letter at her door after
politely getting rid of him she notices
a newspaper report about Jose's arrest
and death sentence overwhelmed with
worry she rushes to the jail disguised
as a lawyer to meet him Jose reveals to
her that he has the ability to bring
creatures back to life as evidenced by
the pterodactyl but he tells her that he
won't be able to help her as long as he
is in prison Adele desperate to save her
sister who is suffering from a hairpin
lodged in her head begs Jose to revive
patmosis who she believes can provide
the Cure however with his current
situation Jose is unable to help as
Adele tries to figure out a plan
unfortunately her cover is blown and she
is thrown out of jail she once again
arrives in a new disguise but the
outcome is the same after many trials
she finally reaches Jose's cell only to
learn that he has been transferred out
of jail and is going to be executed
early in the morning with this Adele
accepts the fact that she can't save
Jose by herself so she decides to seek
the president's help it turns out she
has known the president for quite a
while now and she was one of the first
reporters to interview him after he came
into Power Adele explains the situation
to him highlighting Jose's scientific
credentials and the loss France's
scientific Community would suffer if he
were executed after hearing her out the
president promises to look into the
matter he then throws a ball and orders
his pet dog to fetch it however the
pterosaur who happens to be nearby
mistakes the ball for an egg and attacks
the president Adele watches it all go
down so she quickly Springs into action
and saves him unfortunately no one
notices the giant bird and they assume
that Adele attacked the president hence
she is arrested in the meantime Capone
hires a professional hunter from South
Africa to catch the pterodactyl the
movie then cuts to Maynard's Botanical
Garden where Andres shows him the nest
made by the pterodactyl it's then
revealed that Andres used his extensive
knowledge about dinosaurs to trick the
giant bird into building a nest in the
backyard this blows Menard's mind and so
he commends his Apprentice for his
intelligence the police eventually Adele
from custody and when she returns home
she takes a bath to forget about her
woes while she's at it she decides to
read Andrea's latest letter lo and
behold it reveals that the bird lives in
Maynard's Botanical Garden hoping that
it would lead her to Professor Jose she
rushes to Andre gives him a kiss and
then requests him to take her to the
bird after reaching there Adele quickly
befriends the pterodactyl and uses it to
save Professor Jose from getting
executed they then return to the Garden
as anywhere else is not safe for the
giant Beast Maynard is pleasantly happy
to see Jose as it turns out the two
professors are childhood friends
unfortunately the South African also
arrives there and shoots the pterodactyl
at point-blank range this causes
immeasurable pain to both the Beast and
Jose as their souls appear to be
connected to one another Maynard quickly
snatches the gun from the Hunter and
shoes him away but the damage has
already been done hence with time
running out Adele quickly Springs into
action asking Andre to keep the birds
safe while she and Professor Jose rushed
back to her home to tend to her ailing
sister there the professor makes a
circle of antique things around himself
and starts performing his magic it seems
if he is going to succeed but halfway
through he suddenly loses power and dies
this devastates Adele and she seemingly
gives up however her sorrow is
short-lived as she soon discovers that
Jose actually resuscitated patmosis
before passing away it turns out the
pharaoh's medical doctor was actually
buried right next to him oh that helps
this make sense a flashback then reveals
that Adele's sister got injured during a
tennis match between the two during the
game Adele accidentally struck her
sister on the forehead with the ball as
a result the latter fell on her back
with her head landing on her hairpin the
whole story makes Pat Moses emotional
and he expresses regret over not being
able to help her however he makes a
revelation that Jose's telepathic power
must have resuscitated the dead within a
two kilometer radius this gives it all
hope and she rushes to the Louvre where
the mummy of Ramses II and his servants
have been put on display she takes her
sister and patmosis along with her as
well the latter helps them gain entry
into the museum and when they are almost
caught he puts the guards to sleep
go to sleep in the next scene Adele
locates the mummies and wakes them up
from deep sleep patmosis then explains
her sister's ordeal to the Pharaoh and
requests that he allow his personal
doctor nocebus to cure her however this
only infuriates the Pharaoh as he thinks
he's been Disturbed for such a trivial
Affair just when it appears as if all
hope has been lost Adele bursts into
tears and starts explaining the guilt
she has been harboring for the last five
years she reveals that The Hairpin which
has made her sister permanently disabled
was actually a gift from her upon
hearing this the Pharaoh finally feels
sorry for Adele and allows no seebest to
cure her sister and in just a matter of
seconds the latter removes The Hairpin
from her head afterwards he makes a
magic potion using entrails and uses it
to cover the hole on the sister's
forehead before wrapping a bandage
around her head the Pharaoh then kisses
the girl to conclude the procedure
before leaving with his Entourage let's
go get some sandwiches after a while she
finally wakes up much to the Delight of
Adele They Embrace and Cry tears of joy
while patmosis silently leaves to be
with his friends several weeks later
Andre again shows up at Adele's door but
this time with flowers however when he
doesn't find her there he gives them to
her sister instead this officially
kick-starts their romantic relationship
meanwhile Adele is seen boarding a ship
which is revealed to be RMS Titanic the
movie ends is the evil Professor from
earlier sarcastically wishes her a happy
Journey
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching